as your business grows your applications
are in constant danger of becoming bulky
and sluggish modernization helps you to
stay agile by keeping your app's feeling
like they're fresh out of the box with
IBM cloud you can adopt a truly open
hybrid multi cloud strategy that
leverages your previous investments in
business logic while capitalizing on the
agility flexibility and scalability of
the cloud when it comes to the big
decisions our experience can help you
choose when to simplify and extend
existing applications with containers
and api's or when it's best to decompose
and refactor them using micro services
the idea of modernizing often sounds
like a need to start over but with IBM
cloud you can unlock the potential
that's been trapped within the very
applications that got your business to
where it is today
you